[Music]
peter parker
[Music]
and the girlfriend greetings film
fanatics it's mark ellis and welcome to
a very exciting episode of rt essentials
now we all know peter parker the pride
of aunt may and uncle ben mary jane
suiter science whiz kid aspiring
photographer he's a busy guy but that
doesn't stop him from moonlighting as
spider-man the crime-fighting vigilante
scaling and swinging across skyscrapers
with self-shot bungie webs some of you
may even have a favorite spider-man in
particular maguire garfield holland and
maybe you've stressed yourself out
wondering hey why do they keep changing
the lead like i was just getting used to
seeing a 26 year old toby maguire play a
high schooler now it's andrew garfield
how old's he
fret not my friends because this week
we're diving deep into the history of
the spider-man movies with the upcoming
release of no way home which promises an
unprecedented crossover between the sony
spider-verse and the mcu we figured this
would be a good time to clear out any of
the cobwebs of confusion as to what has
led us to this historical superhero
juncture obviously the expanded history
a little too fast to cover in one vid
made for tv movies like 1977 spider-man
were great and all but let's stick to
the major theatrical releases here
there's plenty of material and i do mean
plenty also be warned that the spoiler
alert is in effect and with that said
let's get swinging
spider-man
hello my dear
it's spiderman
[Music]
welcome to the era of director sam ramey
and lead actor toby maguire in the first
of what became a successful trilogy
peter parker is bitten by a genetically
altered spider gain superhuman powers
and vows to use these new abilities to
fight crime this iteration also
introduced the maniacal villain green
goblin played by the equally maniacal
the great willem dafoe the events
leading up to the release were nothing
short of what is commonly referred to as
development hell going back to the 1980s
marvel comics had their targets set on a
big screen spider-man production with
orion pictures on board and character
co-creator stan lee writing the
screenplay due to budgetary disputes
this never happened so the film rights
were acquired by the canon group and in
1985 after several script variations
things were looking super that is until
superman four the quest for peace bombed
so the cannon group cut their spider-man
budget to a strict seven million dollars
which even for that time wasn't a heroic
figure producer manaham golwan then left
the cannon group and became ceo of the
21st century film corporation where he
extended his option on spider-man and
sold the theatrical rights to carrollco
pictures everybody still with me good
tally ho
[Music]
[Music]
james cameron then became attached to
write and direct the film submitting a
treatment to carroll co in 1993 this
version was a bit darker and
incorporated the villains electro and
sandman the new budget 50 million
dollars all right now we're getting
there oh is that we're not oh right
golan ends up suing carrollcoat pictures
for trying to make the film without him
and the production stalls at this point
cameron said forget it i'm hopping on
the titanic never let go check because
we're almost there in 1995 mgm acquires
21st century film sues viacom sony and
marvel for fraud and in the following
year marvel and carol co pictures file
for bankruptcy but much like the
superheroes themselves marvel would
emerge from the ashes of financial rune
in 1998 and declare the goldwyn
spider-man option had expired and
defaulted back to them and subsequently
in march of 1999 sony pictures would
acquire the film rights from marvel 4.
there's that number again 7 million
after lining up several directors which
included tim burton chris columbus david
fincher and m night shyamalan sony
ultimately hired director sam ramey
citing his youthful passion for the
comic book series as the reason he
earned the job i will never forget these
words
with great power comes great
responsibility
this is my gift
my curse
using cameron's treatment as a blueprint
screenwriter david kept drafted the new
screenplay replacing electro and sandman
with the green goblin and adding in dr
octopus as a second antagonist sony then
hired scott rosenberg to rewrite the
script losing doc ock altogether and
keeping green goblin as the primary
villain principal photography began in
january of 2001 and there you have it
two decades of turmoil from concept to
execution all shenanigans aside it was
well worth the wait rami spider-man
established a new format for superhero
films trading out the campy and trite
for something deep and emotionally
driven the style would go on to
influence smash hits like nolan's the
dark knight trilogy with a budget of 139
million dollars the film earned
821.7 million bucks worldwide and became
sony's highest grossing domestic release
all the way up to 2018 when it was
surpassed by jumanji welcome to the
jungle the film was also a critical
success earning two academy award nods
and a certified fresh score of 90
on the tomato meter spider-man 2.
getting on my nerves i have a knack for
that not anymore
[Music]
sony and ramy strike back again with a
sequel that picks up two years after the
first spider-man maguire is back as
self-doubting peter parker and kirsten
dunst returns as the increasingly
complicated love interest mary jane with
the green goblin defeated there's now a
vacancy for a new villain and after a
freakish lab accident dr otto octavius
emerges as the tentacle-bearing doctor
octopus portrayed by alfred molina randy
drew inspiration from the marvel comic
book version of doctor octopus also
known as doc ock which debuted in 1964
and used storyline elements from 1967's
spider-man no more it's worth noting
that doc ock is also the founder of the
sinister six a super villain team that
shares the common goal of crushing
spider-man word on the street is if
they're getting a movie of their own
keep your tentacles crossed if that
happens
let's see you scurry out of this
[Music]
[Music]
moena's portrayal of doc earned him
legendary villain status with the la
times stating that dachau grabs the film
with his quartet of sinisterly
serpentine mechanical arms and refuses
to let go wait a minute quartet
shouldn't he have eight legs i don't
know math is hard regardless doc ock has
been spotted in the no way home trailers
with molina reprising the role which
we're obviously all very enthused about
spider-man 2 was a mega hit grossing
788.6 million dollars worldwide and
taking home the oscar for best visual
effects but its legacy far surpasses any
quantifiable success many marvel
enthusiasts consider this the gold
standard for superhero flicks partially
due to rammy's history as a hard
director for films like evil dead which
adds a certain gravitas previously
unseen in the genre we even an
outstanding cast a captivating script
state of the art special effects and
you've got yourself a top contender for
the greatest live-action spider-man film
to date
spider-man 3.
the third and final installment in the
rammy verse is 2007's accurately titled
spider-man 3 and brings back maguire and
dunce and features a screenplay
co-written by sam ramy himself just when
parker and mj are finally on the right
track for romance things go south
spider-man's suit turns black and he
struggles to control the dark sides of
his own personality hashtag so emo cue
the death cab for cutie song also the
rise of two super villains sandman and
venom don't exactly make that situation
any easier spider-man 3 already had its
release date set by the time the
previous film hit theaters and
screenwriter alvin sargent who penned
spider-man 2 had signed on to co-write
the script randy helped develop the
treatment pushing to use sandman as a
primary antagonist and giving him more
crucial background than the character
had seen in the comics
flint marco
what do you want from me remember ben
parker
the old man you shot down in cold blood
what does it matter to you anyway
everything
producer and founder of marvel studios
aviarad then convinced the director to
bring venom into the mix citing that he
felt rammy was making biased decisions
about which villains to include in the
series i mean also added supporting
character gwen stacy using her as a
rival love interest to mj so just to
recap deep breath here
we have spider-man fighting for mj's
love while he's also fighting himself
and battling sandman and venom and
dealing with the temptations of gwen
stacy and oh we forgot to mention
quarreling with the green goblin's son
who is seeking revenge for his father's
death in a new persona known as the new
goblin did molina's doc ock prove that a
film only needs one strong antagonist to
get the job done despite the film
earning a domestic gross of
336.5 million dollars it had the worst
critical reception in the series and
although ramy had signed on to direct a
fourth and fifth film he felt he
couldn't reach the demanding deadlines
while upholding the quality and so this
chapter of spider-man had concluded
the amazing spider-man crush
just let me go got a knife
yes it's a real knife my weakness it's
small knives just let me go everything
oh it's so simple that was cool what the
hell is this webbing that i developed
myself i don't think you really want to
know
and now we officially enter the mark
webverse yeah the director's name is
actually mark webb jumping off of the
amazing spider-man which was released
five years after spider-man 3 we said
goodbye to maguire and hello to andrew
garfield as our leading man columbia
pictures aka sony and marvel studios
decided to reboot the series and rather
than pick up where raymie left off in a
new cast and crew and start from scratch
producers aviarad matt tolmec and laura
ziskin wanted a director that could
redefine peter parker and capture the
true essence of the story which they
felt should be about a boy becoming a
man webb had found success with his
directorial debut 500 days of summer and
thought this was an opportunity he
couldn't pass up
[Music]
[Music]
the film basically follows the origin
story of raimi's spider-man parker is
bitten by a radioactive spider gain
superhuman powers and vows to fight
crime in fact this was one of the major
criticisms of webb's film why do we need
to see this again we get it mary jane
has also been replaced by gwen stacy as
parker's love interest and we're
introduced to yet another dark and
menacing villain the lizard it doesn't
quite have the same awards venom or
green goblin but hey scaly skin
thumbs up the lizard first appeared in
the amazing spider-man number 6 in 1963
i was more or less considered a b-bad
guy in the comics so that decision to
make him the main antagonist in the
amazing spider-man left some fans
perplexed the film was a box office
success earning 757.9
million dollars worldwide and received
overall positive reviews with many
applauding garfield and co-star emma
stone's chemistry
the amazing spider-man 2. i'm going to
kill the light
so everyone in this city is going to
know how it feels to live in my world
a world without power
a world without mercy
a world
without spider-man webb and producers
aviaran and matt tolmak return with the
amazing spider-man 2. garfield is still
the lead and stone is still gwen stacy
but as is always the case with a sequel
there is an opening for a new villain or
in this case three new villains jamie
foxx's electro dan dahan is the green
goblin and paul giamatti unforgettably
as rhino much like randy spider-man 3
critics and fans felt that having so
many villains muddled this film which is
partially why it had the worst critical
and commercial reception of any spider
guy movie to date also i warned you
about sporos already right they killed
off the love interest gwen stacy which
just felt out of place and tired at this
point the dark knight had already done
that in 2008 and way more effectively
harry this is between you and me you
want to fight
fight me let her go
[Music]
at the time this film was released 2014
marvel studios had already established
the marvel cinematic universe and had
been cranking out hit after hit after
hit as spider-man had been on a steady
decline since 2007 marvel had released
iron man the incredible hulk iron man 2
captain america the first avenger the
avengers iron man 3 thor the dark world
and captain america the winter soldier
and had also been acquired by disney in
a 4 billion deal and all this in the
span of a few years the pressure was on
for sony and the amazing spider-man 2
just didn't cut it things were looking
bleak for spidey but hope was on the
horizon uh no not for you rhino you can
stay put
captain america civil war
all right i run out of patience
underoos
[Music]
nice job kid
thanks well i could have stuck the
landing a little better it's just a new
suit wait it's nothing mr stark it's
it's perfect thank you yeah we don't
really need to start a conversation okay
captain
big fan spider-man yeah we'll talk about
it later just hey everyone good job wait
i thought this was a spider-man vid well
it was in 2014 the captain america civil
war was conceived with the russo
brothers returning to direct and
christopher marcus and stephen mcfeely
writing the screenplay president of
marvel studios and primary producer of
the mcu kevin feige was eager to build
an even more impressive ensemble cast
for this third installment in the
captain america series his aim was set
on bringing spider-man into the mcu and
so he lobbied sony to cooperate and
allow marvel to use the character sony
wasn't thrilled about the idea and their
potential stakes in the venture they had
publicly announced the development of a
sinister six film replacing webb with
director drew goddard and hoping to
successfully reboot peter parker and
this is where life imitates film
november 24th 2014 sony gets hacked
thousands of private emails are
compromised and the public becomes aware
of sony and marvel's spider-man
discussions now sony had extreme
pressure from fans who desperately
wanted to see the web slinger in the mcu
even stan lee couldn't have made this up
[Music]
that thing does not obey the laws of
physics at all kid there's a lot going
on here that you don't understand stark
said you'd say that
a revolutionary deal was announced in
2015 with a new spider-man debuting in
civil war released by disney and then
that same spider-man starring in a new
standalone movie released by sony and
produced by marvel in 2017. the deal was
simple each studio fully invests and
keeps most of the profits from their
respective features tom holland lands
the part and production for a captain
america film that features spider-man
gets underway spider-man homecoming
which all leads us to 2017's spider-man
homecoming co-produced by columbia
pictures in marvel studios and
distributed by sony pictures the film
stars tom holland michael keaton john
favreau gwyneth paltrow zendaya and
donald glover and it's directed by john
watts unlike the rammy and webb versions
homecoming uses a different origin story
for holland's peter parker yes there's a
mention of tragic events that we assume
his uncle ben related but parker already
fighting crime in this film and working
alongside the avengers specifically tony
stark aka iron man holland was a
teenager in real life which makes his
high school antics a little more
believable than say maguires or garfield
hey karen what else can this suit do
oh what
maybe we should run that refresh of
course
ricochet ricochet
cool
spiderweb
web grenade
not to be confused with birdman or
batman michael keaton is the vulture an
everyday criminal who is contending with
super-powered crime fighters which
humanizes the character and adds a
particular profundity in a role that
could have easily been overblown there's
also a post-credits scene as there
always is where vulture meets matt
gargan aka the scorpion both vulture and
the scorpion are part of the sinister
six which could mean a possible
appearance in no way home more on that
later homecoming was commercially
triumphant earning 880.2
million dollars worldwide and critics
and audiences alike praised tom
holland's performance spider-man was
back
spider-man into the
like this what spider-verse you going
i'm just taking the whole thing
and obviously you've been glitching
glitching no
why would you even say that
you stay in this dimension too long your
body's gonna disintegrate do you know
how painful that would be peter parker i
don't know you can't imagine sony
pictures animation then brings the
groundbreaking computer animated
spider-man into the spider-verse this
film had no connection to the holland
mcu spider-man in fact this is a
completely different spider-man
altogether into the spider verse follows
teenage protagonist miles morales an
alternative to parker who was created by
writer brian michael bendis and artist
sarah pacelli morales teams up with five
other spider-powered individuals from
various dimensions and together they
fight to save the universe phil ward and
rodney rothman were given complete
creative freedom thanks to their wildly
successful direction and writing of the
lego movie in 2014.
i look forward to working with you yeah
yeah yeah me too i guess but i i don't
approve of your methods but uh
we're just gonna have to agree to
disagree
thank you for your bravery tonight
i love you
wait what the film stars shamiq moore
jake johnson haley steinfeld mahershua
ali brian tyree henry nicholas cage left
schreiber and many others critics and
audiences went berserk over this one the
good kind of berserk the film was
praised for its striking animation and
for portraying morales as a biracial
character which made him relatable to a
wider audience it also took home the
oscar for best animated feature film and
has a remarkable 97
on the tomato meter into the spider
burst was dedicated to spider-man's two
creators steve ditko and stan lee who
both died the year the film was released
a fatefully beautiful tribute to the
late legends
avengers infinity war
magic
[Music]
at this point we're deep into marvel's
phase 3 with avengers infinity war this
marks the 19th film in the mcu and the
third avengers film following the age of
ultron the russo brothers once again
direct marcus and mcfeely once again
write the script and kevin feige
produces as he always does infinity war
more like infinity cast am i right
anyone look i'm not going to list
everybody in infinity war for time's
sake but i will point out tom holland
spider-man joins iron man doctor strange
star war drax a destroyer and mantis to
combat the super villain thanos on the
planet titan okay i'm refreshing the
spoiler alert now because even though
you've probably already seen this
considering it's the fourth highest
grossing film of all time parker falls
victim to the blimp yeah the blip when
thanos snaps his fingers and you
remember that half the population
disappears tony stark takes parker's
death deeply personal as he had become a
mentor to the young hero it's a lot of
suffering this loss lights a fire in
iron man and sets up his motivations in
end game and marvel's phase four and
five which further solidifies
spider-man's significance in the mcu
avengers end game
hey queens
heads up
[Music]
hey nice to meet you oh my god
speaking of end game one year later the
same superhero cast and crew returned
and we're back to dealing with thanos
who is decimating the universe at an
alarming rate so much so even the death
star is like dude chill the avengers
must assemble once more and try to undo
some of this destruction though the
previous film had left being seemingly
irreparable all this sets up the epic
return of spider-man towards the end of
the film just in time to help the
avengers take down thanos and in a
tragic
snap of fate tony stark sacrifices
himself killing the super villain but
meeting his own demise in the process
holy cow you will not believe what's
been going on do you remember when we're
in space and i got all dusty and i must
have passed out because i woke up and
you were gone but doctor strange was
there right he was like it's been five
years come on they need us and then he
started doing the yellow sparkly thing
that he does all the time what are you
doing
[Music]
much like how parther's disappearance in
infinity war shattered stark stark's
death and end game weighs heavily on
parker this loss leaves an
unquestionably difficult void to fill
but many feel that these events make
parker a prime candidate to take stark's
place end game shattered numerous box
office records and became the highest
grossing film of all time to the tune of
2.798
billion dollars worldwide which is
almost as much as robert downey jr's
salary for playing iron man i'm kidding
i'm kidding
kind of spider-man far from home
[Music]
do you see anything
yeah
and i'm gonna kill him
[Music]
i hope this works
and after a side step to kill thanos
holland is back as the front man in
spider-man far from home the sequel to
homecoming and the 23rd film in the mcu
kevin feige and amy pascal produce wats
directs and chris mckenna and eric
summers write the screenplay the film
stars samuel l jackson is nick fury and
jake gyllenhaal's mysterio who team up
with spider-man to battle four massive
elemental creatures each representing
earth air water and fire not to be
confused with the protagonists earth
wind and fire
this was the first mcu film to be
released since end game and reckons were
the consequences of a post thanos world
more specifically a world without tony
stark and what that might mean for peter
parker a lot of this is open to
interpretation but the parallels between
stark revealing himself as iron man and
iron man 3 and parker having his
identity revealed and far from home are
undeniable this means that parker could
have a similar story arc and future
significance to stark's position in the
avengers films far from home is the
highest grossing sony pictures movie
ever and the first spider-man flick to
pass the billion-dollar mark
venom let there be carnage do you know
how lucky you are that i
chose you you chose me
buddy i'm the only person that took you
in when your friends kicked you off the
planet mingmon because you are a reject
you are a pariah lethal protection my
ass you couldn't protect anything you
are useless you can get a job down here
cleaning toilets let there be carnage
the sequel to 2018's venom was directed
by andy serkis and produced by columbia
pictures in association with marvel the
film stars tom hardy as eddie brock aka
venom and woody harrelson as cletus
cassidy aka carnage since this is a
spider-man focused video we're going to
fast forward to those post-credits
scenes because that's where those
tantalizing multiverse nuggets are
chilling out for one when eddie brock is
in hiding he mentions a hive that spans
the multiverse then the room starts to
glitch very similarly to an effects
scene and into the spider verse and
eddie appears in a different looking
room but in the same location is that a
multiverse hint there's also speculation
that doctor strange is behind this
glitch based on what he's doing in the
no way home trailer
spider-man no way home we started
getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
peter which takes us to the final puzzle
piece spider-man no way home is set to
release in theaters on december 17 2021
watts directs mckenna and summers wright
fighting pascal produce and tom holland
stars in the third film of the series
and the
do some quick 27th film in the mcu what
do we know well we know dr strange is
trying to make parker's identity as
spider-man a secret again after it's
public revelation and far from home we
know that fox is returning his electro
and molina is returning as doc ock
sandman green goblin and lizard will
likely return as well all of these
villains by the way are members of the
sinister six hashtag epic
you're not gonna take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
to have everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
there's even speculation that toby
maguire and andrew garfield will have
roles making this a potentially
mind-blowing crossover of universes
characters studios storylines and well
peter parker's the tagline in the
trailer promises that the marvel
universe will change forever so you know
we got that going for us no way home is
shaping up to be the biggest spider-man
film in history and possibly one of the
mcu's most successful releases and that
brings us up to speed with the history
of the spider-man movies as always
there's far too many characters and
plots to go over in one vid because i
need a nap now don't go all thanos on me
if i left out one of your favorites
there's plenty more rt essentials vids
on the horizon so i'm sure we'll get to
your favorites eventually i'm mark ellis
and thanks for tuning in oh and remember
that whole great power great
responsibility thing you know how it
goes right
[Music]
you